[Music]
on this Wednesday night Canada's cost of
borrowing climbs yet again the central
bank's Trend setting interest rate takes
another hike we need the economy to slow
the homeowner's hardest hit and what's
your financial forecast
step up to save the planet now the un's
dire warning to countries to bolster
their climate change goals
an Ontario woman's Nightmare how she
says she was wrongfully charged with her
husband's murder a global news exclusive
global national with Donna Friesen
reporting Tonight Eric Sorensen
good evening and thanks for joining us
the Bank of Canada continued its push to
bring down inflation today with yet
another increase to its Benchmark
interest rate today's 50 basis point
rise marks the central bank's sixth hike
in just seven months the rapid hikes
kicked off in March with a quarter point
rise the first increase since October of
2018. in April a further hike of half a
percentage point an identical jump in
June the rate then vaulted an entire
percentage point in July a move not seen
since the 1990s the increases eased
slightly in September with a rise of
three quarters of a point and with
today's Half Point increase the bank
rate now sits at 3.75 percent of figure
last seen in 2008. even though inflation
numbers are slightly improving the
Central Bank says more rate hikes are
likely adding to the economic pain
already being felt by Canadians and
gaviola begins our coverage tonight
another Hefty rate hike with more in the
mail we also expect our policy rate will
need to increase further the bank is
trying to cool the economy to bring
inflation down households and businesses
want to buy more goods and services than
the economy can produce and this is
driving prices up the announcement has
an immediate impact on variable rate
debt including mortgages though
homeowners looking to renew soon as well
as prospective buyers are watching all
of this closely the 50 basis point hike
means this for a typical five-year
variable mortgage on a six hundred
thousand dollar home loan a 165 dollar
increase in monthly payments to
3370. the stress of rapidly Rising
borrowing costs is already taking a toll
on households according to a recent
ipsos poll for financial firm mnp nearly
60 percent of us are concerned and
that's a new record coupled with
inflation at multi-decade highs debt
experts worry about how cash strapped
families will cope this is where the
cycle comes in The Snowball Effect
because if they get more debt that debt
will typically have more interest
because you're likely going to put it on
credit cards or lines of credit and if
those interest rates go up uh they're
going to be in a more difficult
situation politicians of all Stripes
continue to question the central bank's
approach fearing it's gone too far too
fast there are so many Canadians across
this country looking at their mortgages
thinking with this increase will I be
able to afford to keep my home will I be
able to pay my bills that's a real risk
this fear is driving homeowners to seek
help from people like mortgage and real
estate expert Victor Tran I have been
receiving more calls and more emails
than usual especially since the last
rate hike on September 7th the Central
Bank pegs the chance of a recession
likely next year at 50 50 which means
the size of your financial cushion your
appetite for risk and a contingency plan
should all factor into your financial
consideration
and this is the central bank's sixth
hike this year but inflation remains
stubbornly High what do you think
Canadians can expect in the coming
months
Tiff Macklin today reiterated the need
for rates to go higher the majority of
economists and investors do expect
another rate hike from the Bank of
Canada on December 7th at its next
opportunity what happens after that
though is less clear we do know that the
Bank of Canada says it remains committed
to getting inflation closer to its two
percent Target and right now we are a
long way from that Eric
and gaviola in Toronto thank you Anne
Canadian homeowners may feel today's
rate hike the most as Ross Lord explains
some are now thinking it's time to lock
in their mortgage rates before they
climb even higher
excellent you can sit wherever you like
Rising interest rates are making
meetings like this one to finalize a
mortgage agreement a bit more
complicated so what day of the month do
you want your payment to come out on for
home buyer Bruce Herron the hardest part
came beforehand he already locked in his
five-year term I think there's always a
pause when interest rates go up either
50 basis points or you know where we've
come from from two to three percent ish
although he prevented hundreds of
dollars extra every month in mortgage
payments many other homeowners will be
hard-pressed I see the clients that you
know are starting to be impacted by
inflation the clients that might be in
an adjustable rate mortgage that their
payment went up even today with the Bank
of Canada finding the money by cutting
costs elsewhere is harder than ever with
homeowners still facing double-digit
price increases for food and other
Commodities offsetting the higher rates
buying a house costs less overall than
earlier this year and although interest
rates are rising in historical terms
they're still fairly low nothing like
the extreme highs in parts of the 1980s
and lower even than most years before or
since yes I certainly would not be
banking on the Bank of Canada slowing
things down if interest rates keep
Rising homeowners whose locked in rates
are up for renewal in coming months
could also be in for an eye-opening Ross
lore Global News Halifax
you think it's bad here inflation is
even worse in the UK people there are
battling a cost of living crisis not
seen in 40 years consumer Prices rose
10.1 percent in September over last year
it is a real struggle to buy affordable
food and to put heat in homes and the
country's political uncertainty hasn't
helped the new prime minister Rishi
sunak is promising to tackle the
profound economic crisis but as Crystal
gomancing Reports people need help now
this will be 1.20
um a 108 beans is doubled to 1.30
everything's went up the cost of basic
Food Supplies are rising and utilities
are following suit
domestic gas prices Rose 96 percent
based on the government's own data
incomes stretch past their limit people
have hit the breaking points I like the
people who used to donate are no longer
in a position that they can donate you
know because they've lost their
disposable income and some of them
actually come in to the food bank as
well
dad's house is Park Community Center
food bank and advocacy Hub a safe
supportive place for people in turbulent
times measures have been implemented to
ease the burden on people including a
reduction of the fuel Duty by five pence
there's also been a rebate for Council
taxes in a number of areas and a cap on
Energy prices well there has been a lot
of Market turbulence even in the last 48
hours and the question is how you deal
with that turbulence the government
itself has been part of the problem it's
why the last prime minister fired her
Chancellor and handed the financial
portfolio to Jeremy Hunt for stability
he was reappointed by the newest leader
Rishi sunap my record is clear when
times are difficult in this country I
will always protect the most vulnerable
how those words will be put into action
won't be known for three more weeks the
government postponed the release of its
fiscal plan to November 17th Crystal
gemancing Global News London
investors and analysts are expressing
confidence the proposed merger between
Rogers and Shaw can still go ahead
yesterday the industry Minister said the
government will not approve the
wholesale transfer of Wireless Spectrum
licenses between the two companies
putting the 26 billion dollar merger in
doubt but the third party in that deal
Quebec's video Tron says it's willing to
accept The Minister's conditions for its
purchase of Freedom mobile from Shaw
another condition is the expectation
Wireless prices will be lowered by up to
20 percent in Ontario and western Canada
foreign
still some Hang-Ups for another proposed
merger the federal competition Bureau is
Raising concerns that westjet's purchase
of sun wing vacations would likely
result in higher prices and decreased
service for Canadian Travelers both
Airlines dispute that finding WestJet
says it expects the deal will still get
the necessary Federal approval and close
by the spring
the United Nations is urging countries
to strengthen their climate change
commitments following a new report that
says current pledges are insufficient to
limit the rise in global temperatures to
the current 1.5 degree Target
and the Big Challenge lies within these
T20 countries it's important to get the
whole G20 family on board uh because
that that group is responsible for 80
percent of the global global global uh
emission
under current climate pledges the report
says global temperatures are set to rise
between 2.1 and 2.9 degrees Celsius by
2100 even if countries meet their
commitments which researchers say many
will not the world's current trajectory
means extreme events like intense
flooding wildfires and drought will
happen more often in the future
two Canadian women who left the country
to join Isis then were held for years in
a detention camp in Syria are now back
in this country along with two children
both women were arrested upon arrival
but one Kimberly polman is no longer in
custody as Mercedes Stevenson reports
the repatriation represents an about
faced by the federal government which
had previously refused to help bring
Canadian citizens out of the camps
Isis is a shadow of its former self
degraded from menace to nuisance but the
brutality inflicted by the terror group
has not been forgotten and there has
been little sympathy or political will
to help Canadians who joined Isis make
their way home that changed Tuesday
after weeks of secret negotiations when
the Canadian government took custody of
two Canadian women Kimberly Pullman and
umai mashway as well as schwei's
children in Northeast Syria a dramatic
change from the government's previous
position of refusing to help Canadians
get out of the camps hours after the
women left Syria another first last
night
rsmp officers arrested umai mashway at
the Montreal Trudeau Airport
both women were charged with terrorism
offenses when they landed in Canada
another major shift in what the RCMP had
long said was not possible gathering
enough evidence from Syria to lay
charges in Canada in Syria it is alleged
that she participated in Terrorist
activities in the name of the Islamic
State shui faced terrorism charges in a
Quebec courtroom while Pullman has been
put under a terrorism bond in BC both
women suffered from health problems
which made them eligible under a new
policy adopted by the government in 2021
but Pullman's lawyer said many Canadians
in the detention camps are in the same
situation and it's time to bring more
home as several other Allied countries
have it demonstrates once again that the
Canadian government is capable and
without incident able to
repatriate our Canadian citizens there
the government has been under increasing
pressure by human rights groups the
United Nations and the NDP to bring home
Canadians especially young children
these are Canadian children and living
in abhorrent conditions their lives are
at risk and they are children the
liberal government would not say if
these cases are the beginning of
bringing home all Canadians but hinted
they have a road map now we continue to
engage responsibly in the region uh
monitor closely we have a framework
around doing this we've seen a couple of
situations already but it's important
that people who travel for the purpose
of supporting terrorism uh face
consequences with the 2021 policy for
those with health conditions and the
rcmp's ability to now lay charges may be
a game changer for the government but
just how much political risk Justin
Trudeau is willing to take remains to be
seen Eric
Mercedes Stevenson in Ottawa thank you
an Ontario woman in her own words
coming up why she says she was
wrongfully accused of her husband's
murder
[Music]
a jury in Michigan has convicted three
men of aiding a plot to kidnap State
Governor Gretchen Whitmer the group was
found guilty on three counts connected
to the 2020 plot they face up to 20
years in jail prosecutors said the men
were members of a militia group that
targeted Whitmer because of the pandemic
restrictions she imposed ten others were
arrested in connection with the plot but
not all have been convicted
we the jury find the defendant Daryl e
Brooks guilty of first degree
intentional homicide
the man who drove a speeding SUV into a
Christmas parade in Waukesha Wisconsin
last November has been found guilty on
all charges six people died in the
attack including an eight-year-old boy
and several members of the dancing
grannies group prosecutors convinced the
jury that Daryl Brooks intentionally
drove his SUV through the parade after
getting into a fight with his
ex-girlfriend he faces a mandatory life
sentence
now to a global news exclusive the story
of an Ontario woman who says she was
wrongfully charged with murder she says
the accusations destroyed her life and
as Karen Lieberman explains she's now
fighting to piece it all back together
when you're locked up in a you know a
room that has no real light and you
can't see the sky outside and you can't
have that fresh air and those are things
that everyone takes for granted every
single day for six weeks Melissa
Sheridan sat in a jail cell accused of a
crime she didn't commit I was confused
how they could ever think I had
something to do with this in October
2020 Brant Burke Sheridan's husband from
whom she'd been separated was found dead
on a trail in Killarney Ontario he'd
been shot in the back twice at close
range a month later she asked me to step
out of the vehicle and told me that I
was being charged with Brant Burke's
murder and it was a first degree murder
charge she would later learn it was
Burke's brother Carrie who had
implicated her after he confessed to the
killing it actually blew my mind to know
that I was arrested for a crime I didn't
commit Carrie Burke claims he and
Melissa had been intimate and that she'd
offered him cash and the home he and
Brent were living in to carry out the
murder I was automatically remanded on
suicide watch for 24 hours no
opportunity to phone home no contact
with her young son and daughter describe
the conditions when you were in jail
there's no sleep right the lights are
always on you're never in darkness you
know it's Mouse infested when Sheridan
was finally released on strict Bale
conditions her children were not allowed
to live with her they ruined my life
they've ruined my reputation they've
damaged my children for nearly 20 months
in the eyes of the law and her community
Sheridan was considered an accused
killer when we were finally able to go
to a preliminary trial and after what
was supposed to be three days was a
couple hours and then the crown withdrew
the charge there's never even been an
acknowledgment of the mistake right the
travesty that was done Sheridan has
given notice that she intends to sue the
Ontario Provincial Police and the
wickwemikong Tribal Police as the murder
took place on First Nation territory
Council for police declined to comment
given the matter is before the courts
and it's about trying to recover some
compensation for what's been done to her
for the last two years for which the
police still haven't apologized Sheridan
says her life may never be back to
normal it's very disappointing that this
is where our justice system is at and
that there's no like repercussions and
there's no acknowledgment of the Grave
mistake that was made if this happened
to her she says it can happen to anyone
Karen Lieberman Global News Toronto
and we have this update in the case late
today Carrie Burke Brant Burke's brother
was sentenced to life in prison with no
chance of parole for 15 years
[Music]
cleaning product cleanup ahead wide
scale recall of a popular brand
more than 500 Canadian gymnasts are
renewing their calls for the federal
government to launch an investigation
into their sport
I believe our survivors and children
deserve to be protected and a national
inquiry is that first meaningful step to
make gymnastics safer
gymnasts for change Canada has released
a letter calling on Canada's Sports
minister to launch an investigation into
what it calls the toxic culture
entrenched in Canadian gymnastics last
week gymnastics Canada signed on to work
with a new office of the sport Integrity
commissioner but gymnasts for change
says it will not move forward with a
commissioner assessment because it lacks
the substance and scope to tackle the
problems
China has begun administering what's
believed to be the world's first
inhalable covid-19 vaccine it works by
sucking a Mist in through the mouth for
now it's being offered in Shanghai as a
free booster dose there are no vaccine
mandates in China but stiff restrictions
are in place Health officials hope the
needle-free alternative will encourage
more people to get the vaccine
popular cleaning brand Clorox is
recalling 37 million bottles of its
Pine-Sol cleaners there are fears they
may be contaminated with harmful
bacteria the company says three Pine-Sol
scents are being recalled lavender clean
lemon fresh and Mandarin sunrise in
Canada 7.6 million products made between
January 2021 and September 2022 are
under recall affected bottles also share
the date code you can see on screen
Clorox says the bacteria can be harmful
to those with weaker immune systems and
poses a risk of serious infection and
that's global national for this
Wednesday night I'm Eric Sorensen
tonight's your Canada is twilling gate
Newfoundland and Labrador thanks for
watching and have a good night
thank you